coquet
et fait donc mentaux les samantha
raquette en effet août à la tête qui
tourne ma main je sais pas comment
expliquer ça picote un peu mais ça c'est
comme si tu crées un prix changent tous
les cochons à new york un art faites
attention le snu c'est illégal
alerte il faut absolument dénoncer ce
type de dispositif c'est un produit
addictif
c'est un produit nocif et certains
produits qui se présente comme étant un
produit banal qui est investi par les
jeunes
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le snu c'est quoi c'est du tabac qui se
présente sous forme de poudre dans un
sachet or c'est ce qu'on appelle le
tabac orale il se consomme par diffusion
de la nicotine à l'intérieur de la
cavité buccale
on le met entre la lèvre et la gencive
et donc on voit bien que avec les
muqueuses la concentration de nicotine
est très importante et arrivent
rapidement au niveau du cerveau c'est
dire que la wii de l'uefa va jouer dix
minutes a capté je suis pas comme en
foot et ouais diminue de lever fait très
haut niveau au niveau de la tête tu sens
que je ne fais pas du th mlf avons très
vite eu quand j'en ai pris je sais que
les premières sensations base c'est très
fort et c'est même un goût acide et ça
peut devenir un objectif parce que hba
ta c'est environ tout du tabac et donc
les risques liés au tabac sont les mêmes
que ceux que l'on retrouve avec du tabac
fumé avec la combustion sert la
cigarette et tous les autres formes de
tabac on a retrouvé dans une littérature
scientifique
les liens entre cancer du pancréas et la
consommation du sinus ça c'est important
on a aussi retrouvé aussi des lésions
gingivale avec parfois une lettre
d'invitation à la gencive
lorsqu'on arrête de consommer le snu ce
donc ce sont des lésions réel ses 30 ans
et puis ça d'être les gencives j'ai
rencontré des gens qui étaient
consommateurs de piano un plus
il avait déjà retrouve dans
gencives directement
je sais affecté innover et négocié bon
en tout cas je pense que wes les moins
nocifs parce que je sais pas une filière
et de faire suer c'est vraiment un
poumon et une certaine chaleur qui qu'on
en fait et que tu vois on comprend alors
que là je suis simplement un simple mot
shoah acquis des choses en attaque on
est toujours là jean philippe a capté on
a fait un très gros coup de froid et au
bout de fin du monde qui l'enlève
définie comprend un autre alors quand on
dit que le snu cm nocif que la cigarette
on fait référence à ce qu'on appelle à
combustion
donc il ya d'autres d'autres effets
délétères du snu mais si vous vous
comparez ce nice avec le tabac on n'a
pas l'effet de la combustion parce que
l'effet de la combustion rapporte
rappelle assez rapidement les effets
liés les effets qui sont à l'origine des
cancers broncho pulmonaires en revanche
les effets délétères du snu ce sont ceux
que je viens de citer et qui sont à ma
foi tout à fait tout à fait entendre à
bhl et puis surtout le snu êtes un
marchepied par la conçoit consommation
de tabac
lorsque vous consommez disney vous avez
plus de constance et de concentration de
nicotine et que l'addiction lé
dose-dépendante aussi donc forcément un
moment donné lorsque vous consommez du
snu ce vous avez consommé régulièrement
de ce musée si un jour vous n'avez pas
tous nous sert de ce tabac orale vous
êtes obligés de consommer du tabac
normal avec de la combustion pour
pouvoir gérer le manque le manque de
nicotine
je pense que pour des fumeurs sap est
une forme alternative mais
sondant regarder en termes de santé je
ne pense pas que c'est beau une chose
groupe band
le snu ce n'est pas une alternative à la
cigarette donc c'est pas parce que on
consomme de la nicotine et qu'on en
parle à combustion comme pour autant on
est sur un principe actif médicamenteux
ou bien de substitution qui est contrôlé
d'abord parce que ce sont des produits
qui sont fabriqués et distribués de
manière illégale illicite dont elles ne
sont pas ces produits ne sont pas
contrôlés interdite partout en europe ne
connaît pas la quantité mais la
concentration de nicotine
par exemple lorsque vous prenez la
vaporeuse on à la concentration de
nicotine qui n'est pas le cas du snes et
lorsqu'on est sur un dispositif pour
arrêter de consommer du tabac à
combustion on diminue en mesure et en
avance ce n'est pas le cas avec le snes